I know how many just hurt bad my mom's
pageant season she already started hood
guy all right
dumpling the other side Oh
okay darlin just grab my ankles my name
is will Dean Dixon all right
Willa Dean Papo most people call me will
SEP 4 my mom who calls me dumpling I
can't be late this cannot exactly drive
itself being a bit of a celebrity around
here meant that she was too busy for me
you've got a hole in your left by the
way what
this must be your daughter that's my
daughter's best friend this is my
daughter really Dean okay and that's
when I decided enough was enough I know
that look what's going on I think I'm
gonna sign up for the pageant it's gonna
be like protesting it will attain opal
hey y'all you're signing up I am too
wait no I'm not - Jonah Orca fat girls
gonna be so much fun totally fun
pageants are harder than you think I'm
Rosie Dickson's daughter it runs amok we
really have to play to our strengths my
strengths are hula hoop and I could tap
dance hi no no stop it
I think I know where we can get some
help what is this place it's the closest
thing you can get to Dolly Parton around
here
dumpling I don't understand why are you
doing this it's a protest we're trying
to make a point really Dean Dyson I
think you're beautiful
to hell with anyone else has ever made
you feel less than that there's nothing
in the rules that says big girls need
not apply
I'll call myself into something but now
I don't know what I'm doing you know
that Kylie's saying figure out who you
are and do it on purpose
[Music]
viva la revolucion baby that was truly
surprised
[Music]